Bollywood you've had experience and you
were quite successful in Bollywood
yeah himself I mean relatively you know
how Adam Sandler is to you guys yeah I'm
not that famous you didn't quite hit
that mark no I didn't quite I was in
Bollywood movies and am in Bollywood
movies
they're very different Bollywood and
Hollywood very different I think there's
probably this perception that Bollywood
is all singing and dancing in in
Bollywood films well it is because
bollywood bollywood is this aspirational
magical place but it's singing post
killing there's real drama
there's real dramas right I think like
would you guys do an action and planning
we make up in pasion
like I think we're we're better at love
then American movies and I say that with
all due respect loving American rom-coms
right but that stuff just doesn't apply
to us like I've been wanting to do an
American rom-com for a long time but I'm
like what is the standard rom-com trope
it's like a guy he's running through an
airport he's like Roberto
I gotta find Rebecca yeah and and then
like Americans get together and you like
we have to help him he loves Rebecca
right oh I love this movie by the way
yeah I've seen it 50 times I mean I know
they I know exactly what you're talking
but always running through an airport I
gotta get to Rebecca
what's an old guy who's like Rebecca
yeah and people are like we have to help
him I don't think there's a Rebecca yeah
but you can't imagine me just was
Rebecca you know at an airport
I'm brown and I have a beard I'll get
shot in the air
he's the name of his God open fire just
saying you can't go running an airport
says Oh anywhere like yeah right
in New York they always chasing the taxi
on foot Allah come back I love you an
Indian man wouldn't chase a taxi on foot
we just get into our own tax
[Laughter]